is it true that you're a banana delivery
girl in new zealand i think i was the
first um yeah the first official banana
delivery person in wellington i i used
to ride around on a scooter um
and i had the stack of banana boxes on
the back of my scooter and then
unfortunately i blew over it's a very
windy city i blew over um twice and
outside the same cafe so i moved to a
hearse and i was delivering bananas out
of a hearse for a little while is a
hearse the same thing in new zealand as
it is here yeah that's not a lost in
translation thing that's like a
coffin in the back wow yeah delivering
bananas yep did people want the bananas
from a
horse they didn't actually know the
details kelly okay okay you're like just
pulling up and they're like wait what
the tricky trade i'm like guys don't be
alarmed that's not what you think
no emergency bananas
it's a great day i love that um another
thing that you did earlier in your
career is you wanted to be a rapper
right were you rapping i did i i won't
put you through that today i um i wasn't
like one of those people who was sitting
on a wealth of talent that was
undiscovered it wasn't like one of those
stories you're gonna hear where like i
can't believe she didn't get scouted it
was you're like a comedian no i was i
was a terrible rapper a terrible rapper
but who are your favorites well growing
up at like by the beach bohemian kind of
new zealand lifestyle i discovered tupac
and oh finally felt really seen oh my
god yeah
i don't know
why
he related yeah you related to the core
messages there
yeah that's amazing you should be a
comedian
oh gosh oh my god i love you
[Music]
you